madame Marie-George Buffet co-présidente
du Comité national pour renforcer
l'éthique et la vie démocratique dans le
sport et Monsieur Stéphane
Diagana coprésident du comité
national toujours pour renforcer
l'éthique et la vie démocratique dans le
sport madame la ministre monsieur je
monsieur je vous souhaite la bienvenue
et vous remercie de votre disponibilité
pour répondre à nos questions nous avons
entamé les travaux de cette commission
d'enquête le 20 juillet dernier nos
travaux portent sur trois axes les
violences physiques sexuelles ou
psychologiques dans le sport les
discriminations sexuelles et raciales et
les problématiques liées à la
gouvernance financière des organismes de
gouvernance du monde sportif madame la
ministre vous êtes élu député en 1997
puis nommé ministre de la Jeunesse et
des Sports fonction que vous occupez
jusqu'en
2002 monsieur vous avez été athlète
spécialiste du 400 m est champion du
monde d'athlétisme masculin lors des
Championnats du monde d'athlétisme de
1997 à athenne vous mettez fin à votre
carrière sportive en 2004 vous avez
présidé la Ligue nationale l'athlétisme
de 2007 à 2009 en mars
2023 la ministre des Sports installe un
comité national pour renforcer l'éthique
et la vie démocratique dans le sport que
vous
co-présidez la décision de créer ce
comité est directement lié aux affaires
la porte et le GR ce comité est composé
de 12 personnalités qualifiées et doit
formuler d'ici la fin de l'automne 2023
des propositions sur trois axes une
gouvernance du sport plus
éthique une meilleure vitalité
démocratique au sein des instances une
protection renforcée des pratiantes et
des pratiants notamment contre toutes
les formes de violence et de
discrimination
avant d'en venir aux travaux de ce
comité permettez-nous de ne revenir avec
l'ancienne ministre chargé des sports
que vous êtes sur l'affaire qui a
constitué un tournant historique dans la
lutte contre les violences sexuelles
nous nous devons collectivement de
comprendre pourquoi il a fallu attendre
aussi longtemps et la médiatisation de
témoignage aussi accablant que celui de
Sarah beitball en 2020 pour que les
pouvoirs publics se décide à avancer sur
ce
sujet madame sarah bitball a déclaré
devant nous j'avais signalé la situation
au président de la section artistique de
mon club me rendant chez lui avec mon
oncle afin de ne pas être seul pour
parler de ces choses horribles
malheureusement je n'ai pas été entendu
c'était comme si
j'évoquais un simple une simple douleur
au genou il m'a dit d'aller déposer
poser plainte et que nous en
reparlerions
ensuite en un mot il me remerciait
gentiment alors que je venais de dire ce
qui m'était arrivé à l'âge de 15 ans et
de demander qu'on éloigne du club cet
entraîneur
dangereux j'ai également signalé des
faits au ministère où l'on m'a dit qu'il
existait un dossier mais qu'il valait
mieux fermer les yeux pour ce qui est du
dossier je n'ai su que plusieurs années
plus tard ce qu'il en était
Marie-George Buffet avait éloigné Gill
Bayer de la fédération et l'avait
suspendu pendant 6 mois il a ensuite été
réintégré grâce à la Fédération
française des sports de glace s'occupant
notamment des compétitions
internationale junior je n'ai jamais pu
avoir ce dossier dans les mains mais je
sais aujourd'hui grâce à l'enquête menée
par Emmanuel anison que tout y figure et
que désormais il peut en avoir il peut
au moins être lu je ferme les guillemets
nous avons demandé la transmission de ce
dossier au ministère pourquoi a-t-il
fallu attendre la sortie en janvier 2020
du livre de Sarah bitball ainsi long
silence pour que Gilles Bayer soit
suspendu du club des Français Volants
puis exclu en février 2020 il nous
semble important de revenir avec vous
sur la chronologie des faits début 2020
alors que vous êtes ministre des Sports
votre cabinet est saisi par les parents
d'une jeune patineuse du club danger qui
dénonce le comportement de Gilles biller
à l'égard de leurs filles lors d'un
stage de l'été
1999 à la ville de La Roche surion je
rajouterai où je suis élu un premier
rapport est demandé par votre directeur
de cabinet au directeur régional de la
jeunesse et des sports
d'île-de-fance la
DRJS recommande une saisine de l'egsr ce
qui est fait monsieur byer sera suspendu
en mai 2001 Monsieur Bayer est recruté
comme chargé de mission comme entraîneur
auprès du président du club des Français
Volants ni le club ni la Fédération
française des sports de glace ne
tiennent donc compte du
rapport vous exerciez alors la tutelle
de la Fédération avez-vous été courant
en mai 2001 de ce recrutement comment
avez-vous
réagi je rappelle que cette audition est
ouverte à la presse et qu'elle est
retransmise en direct sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale avant de vous
laisser la parole et d'entamer nos
échanges je vous rappelle que l'article
6 de l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires impose aux
personnes entendu par une commission
d'enquête de prêter serment de dire la
vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité je vous invite donc à lever la
main droite chacun à votre tour et à
dire je le jure après avoir activé votre
micro je le
jure je
l'AC je le
jure je vous remercie et vous avez la
parole il était précisé madame la
Présidente je vous remercie que nous
puissions en début de de cette audition
dire quelques mots et je vais répondre
bien sûr à la question aux questions que
vous posez mais vous verrez que c'est
très en
lien donc le comité pour l'éthique et la
vie démocratique dans le sport s'est mis
en place le 29 mars depuis nous avons
entendu 107 personnes dans 70 auditions
bien sûr des acteurs et des actrices du
mouvement sportifs mais aussi des
lanceurs d'alerte mais aussi des
institutions de notre République en
charge
de mission de contrôle et puis des
représentants de l'État à travers des
représentants du ministère
du constat que nous avons
fait à la fois un constat où bien sûr
nous sommes amenés à souligner le fait
parce qu'il faut jamais
l'oublier que c'est par les associations
sportives et leurs bénévoles que le
droit à la pratique sportive est assuré
dans notre pays en partenariat avec
l'État que ce mouvement sportif joue
donc un rôle
considérable mais ce mouvement sportif
et c'est l'objet également de V notre
commission d'enquête est extrêmement
fragilisé il est fragilisé par manque de
politique publique depuis des années
conséquentes il est fragilisé parce
que règne dans le mouvement sportif un
entre soi une
culture qui fait que ce mouvement
sportif a du mal à se saisir des
exigences sociétales sociales éthiques
de notre
époque un mouvement
sportif qui aurait besoin d'un profond
renouvellement c'est pour cela que je
pense personnellement parce que les
travaux du comité sont en cours et je ne
peux pas parler au nom du Comité je
parle à mon nom
personnel je pense que la question de la
vie démocratique dans le mouvement
sportif est une question primordiale
parce que c'est peut-être par une vie
démocratique réel que nous allons
aboutir à un renouvellement des
instances à un débat interne dans les
instances permettant d'affronter le
combat éthique de façon nouvelle en le
débarrassant quelque part de cette
fameuse culture entre guillemets de cet
entesoi qui règne trop souvent
donc cela va demander très certainement
de
modifier les lois électorales au sein
des fédérations
sportive d'aller vers une représentation
à la proportionnelle dans le mouvement
sportif afin de permettre un débat
interne et d'avancer sur les questions
de la parité parce que plus on aura de
femmes dans les instances dirigeantes du
mouvement sportif plus on sera armé au
niveau du combat pour
l'éthique si on arrive à faire bouger
par un renouveau
démocratique il faut en parallèle se
donner les outils pour le combat
éthique des outils qui soient à la
fois responsabilisant pour le mouvement
sportif il faut se donner des outils
internes au mouvement sportif qui soient
efficac mais il faut certainement aussi
réfléchir à comment il y a des
interventions
extérieures Stéphane sera certainement
amené à compléter mon propos nous allons
nous travaillons à très nombreuses
propositions
concernant une architecture nouvelle au
niveau des comités d'éthique de leur
pouvoir de leur composition de leur
transparence et sur la protection des
pratiquants et des pratiquants et je
vais venir à vos questions nous avons
besoin de faire en
sorte je vais juste vous raconter un
moment qui
peut-être m'a énormément motivé dans ces
auditions
nous avons auditionné des jeunes
athlètes à l'INSEP et il y a un jeune
athlète qui a eu cette phrase il a dit
j'aimerais que de temps en temps je ne
sois plus considéré comme un
sportif mais tout simplement comme un
individu c'est-à-dire dans la protection
des pratiquantes et des pratiquants il
faut bien
sûr une réforme systémique de la
formation des éducateurs des entraîneurs
des moyens de contrôle mais il faut
aussi que les athlètes ces hommes et ces
femmes ces jeunes gens ces jeunes filles
soi considérés comme des individus à
parentière avec des
droits droit au respect et cetera et
droit à la parole qu'il puisse prendre
la parole par rapport à leur condition
de préparation à le condition
d'encadrement et cetera alors vous
m'avez posé madame la présidente des
questions sur une affaire qui remonte à
a 20
ans mais cette culture c'est entre
soi existait il y a 20 ans
euh l'idée
que il n'y avait pas eu Mitou il n'y
avait pas eu tout ça à l'époque et donc
c'était encore la chape de plomb sur des
achissements relevant des violences seis
et sexuelles était encore plus relevé
encore plus des nonit dans la société
toutous entière et donc dans la société
et donc dans le mouvement sportif
renforcé dans le mouvement sportif parce
que le mouvement sportif c'est à la fois
le rapport au corps c'est le corps dans
l'espace public et puis c'est l'apport
du sport à la construction psychique et
physique des individus donc ce qui
existait dans la société existait et
existe dans le mouvement sportif mais
avec des spécificités liées aux missions
du sport
lui-même est-ce que le ministère à
l'époque a réagi comme il aurait dû j'ai
envie de vous dire ça
serait scandaleux que je vous réponde
mais bien sûr non non certainement qu'à
l'époque cette affaire ne nous a pas
éveillé sur le fait que cette affaire
n'était pas quelque chose de singulier
mais était quelque chose qui devait
exister dans le mouvement sportif
ailleurs dans cette fédération mais dans
d'autres fédérations également autant le
ministère a été capable à l'époque de de
faire des Assises du sport féminin
ou la question de la plus grande
participation l'accès plus grand des
femmes à la pratique sportive la place
des femmes dans les fédérations tout ça
on le posait mais on n pas posé à cette
époque là la question des
conditions voilà
d'encadrement des conditions de respect
des individus à l'intérieur du mouvement
sportif on l'a fait par rapport au
dopage mais j'ai envie de dire
c'était peut-être que je dirais j'aurais
pas dit ça 20 ans ça paraaît aujourd'hui
plus facile parce que on a le contrôle
le contrôle permet de de de de de de
dire la personne est responsable et si
elle est responsable on a les sanctions
et cetera et on a réussi à mener une
campagne internationale sur ces
questions ça n'a pas été le cas sur la
question du
respect physique et psychique des des
sportifes et des sportifs de la part des
entraîneurs et et des éducateurs donc
oui nous n sommes pas suffisamment
saisis à époque du drame qu'a vécu
madameb mais d'autres aussi je rappelle
que des révélations de Madame moyen de
bec et d'autres nous n'avons pas été à
l'époque au niveau de ce qu'il aurait
fallu pour se saisir de ces dossiers
c'est pour moi je ne ça me paraît clair
oui alors sur le le merci de de nous
recevoir sur le travail de la commission
je je partage les les mots qui ont été
prononcés et l'exposé de Madame buffet
j'ajouterai aussi sur la
fragilité du mouvement sportif
elle repose aussi sur le le
bénévolat qui
aujourd'hui arrive en en limite de
compéten bien souvent par rapport à
l'étendue de de la mission et des
responsabilités qui sont assumer donc
très très clairement le ça ne dédouine
pas le mouvement sportif de sa
responsabilité mais ça nécessite qu'il a
une réflexion sur sa structuration sur
l'accompagnement la formation des
bénévoles l'encadrement supérieur à ce
qui est en place aujourd'hui comp tenu
des exigences sociétales qui sont tout à
fait légitime en la matière et que dont
le mouvement sportif ne peut s'exclure
au au niveau du club au niveau des
comités au niveau des ligues au niveau
des
fédérations quand avez-vous prévu de
remettre vos propositions à la ministre
des Sports des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques on s'est donné pour
objectif de remettre nos
proposition début décembre bon dans les
premières premier première quinzaine de
décembre en sachant que notre souhait au
niveau du comité et là je peux parler au
niveau du comité c'est
vraiment que ce ces propositions et
j'espère les vôtres également soit mis
en
débat pourquoi je dis ça il y a eu une
loi en 2017 il y a eu une loi en 2022 il
y a eu la mise en place des comités
d'éthiqu il y a eu ceci il y a eu cela
mais quand on regarde précisément vous
avez encore des fédérations Olympiques
qui n'ont pas de comité d'éthique vous
avez encore des comités d'éthique qui
sont saisis uniquement par le président
de la Fédération on voit bien que les
lois qui sont votées sans étude d'impact
sans évaluation et sans être partagé par
le mouvement sportif et bien ne sont pas
efficaces donc la suggestion du comité
d'éthique c'est de vraiment mettre
toutes ces propositions en débat au sein
des du mouvement sportif mais pas
seulement il faut aussi que les élus des
collectivités territoriales soient
associés et je dirais plus largement
est-ce qu'il n'est pas temps dans notre
pays qu'on ait un débat public sur sur
les enjeux du développement de la
pratique sportive dans notre pays sur
l'éthique dans le sport sur la vie
démocratique du M sportif est-ce que ça
ne vaut pas le coup qu'on mette en débat
pendant quelques mois ces questions et
moi mon mon souhait
personnel c'est que ça aboutisse à une
loi cadre c'est-à-dire qu'on se dise ça
fait des années et des années qu'on n
pas revisité l'ensemble des enjeux du
sport il est temps de s'y pencher mais
faisons-le après un débat un débat
structuré il s'agit pas de faire
semblant de débattre en mettant les
propositions mais un débat structuré
organisé permettant de faire remonter si
le mouvement sportif se saisit de ses
propositions peut-être
peut-être peut-être on va réussir à
faire en
sorte a des changements assez profonds
en son sein dans dans sa façon d'aborder
les les questions d'aujourd'hui donc je
j'espère qu'on arrivera à mener ce
débat vous avez dit qu'il n'y a pas de
il y a encore des comité olympique qui
n'ont pas de comité
d'éthique fédération olympique qui n'ont
pas de comité d'éthique lesquels j'ai
pas je peux vous fournir laalist je l'ai
pas devant moi mais je pense qu'il était
16 le dernier pointage qu'on avait fait
on était à 16 fédérations olympide qui
n'avait pas encore mis en place l'ÉÉ des
tites alors bien sûr votre pointage il
date de quand oh il y
a je sais pas un mois oui un mois un
mois mais faut bien penser que dans les
fédérations olympiques il y a des
grandes fédérations puis il y a des
fédérations très qui ont des moyens très
réduitis et quand je dis des moyens
c'est pas simplement des moyens
financiers c'est aussi un problème
parfois de compétences hein pour mettre
en place ces ces instruments de combat
pour l'éthique euh voilà oui oui je
crois que pour bien appréhender la la la
diversité he du mouvement sportif et des
fédérations euh il y a des fédérations
qui ont qui ont des budgets qui sont
même pas la taille de club et je parle
pas de club professionnel hein mais de
de club amateurs donc on va de de de
budget allant de de 100000 € euh pour
les plus faibles à 260 260 millions
d'euros pour les plus grosses
fédérations donc forcément vous n'avez
pas les mêmes moyens euh les mêmes euh
voilà niveau de formation pour ces pour
ces différentes fédérations donc là il y
a un enjeu peut-être aussi euh et c'est
une question que l'on se pose de d'organ
transversal euh sur les questions
d'éthique pour pouvoir
suppl à à des carences en la matière et
des difficultés que peuvent avoir des
petites fédérations pour prendre en
compte comme il se doit c'est c'est
problématique avez-vous suivi les les
travaux de cette commission d'enquête et
qu'en avez-vous
pensé chaque fois que j'ai
pu me libérer pour écouter j'ai
écouté bien évidemment votre commission
d'enquête et c'est sa vocation sa
mission
vous êtes très sur des des cas des
situations des problématiques très
précise le comité lui s'est plus tourné
à partir d'un constat plus global de
l'état du mouvement sportif des
problèmes posés pour l'éthique et la
protection des pratiquantes et
pratiquants c'est plus tourné vers
l'élaboration de propositions comme
vient de le dire monsieur Stéphane
Diagana de propositions qui peuvent être
applicable être effectif dans l'ensemble
du mouvement sportif quel que soit les
moyens les tailles des
fédération je reprends la question de
l'éthique si nous avons des fédérations
qui sont en difficulté pour faire vivre
un comité d'éthique il faut peut-être se
poser la question quel pourrait être le
rôle du Comité national olympique et
sportif français comme
impulseur comme
soutien au combat pour les titres dans
des f qui par le dimension n'ont pas
toujours les moyens de mener ce combat
en interne est-ce que on n pas à définir
un rôle nouveau du
CNOSF dans ce combat politique le comité
pencherait plutôt vers
cette cette
solution merci merci
beaucoup moi je vais revenir un peu sur
les comités puisque je pense que c'est
vraiment justement un outil qui est
indispensable aujourd'hui au sein de ces
fédérations on sera preneur de la liste
effectivement de ceux qui n'ont toujours
pas de comité d'éthique je le dis parce
qu'on a eu l'occasion d'entendre et la
direction des sports et la ministre qui
nous indiquait qu'il n'y avait plus que
deux fédérations qui n'avaient plus de
comité qui n'avaient pas de comité
d'éthique donc si vous nous dites qu'il
y en a 16 bah ça nous intéresse
forcément de savoir quelles sont ces
fédérations qui ne les ont pas et par
ailleurs de très nombreux acteurs que
nous avons entendu y compris d'ailleurs
les fédérations ont appelé à la création
d'une autorité indépendante sur les
sujets qui intéressent cette commission
d'enquête la ministre a semblé avoir
déjà tranché cette question sur laquelle
vous vous êtes peut-être également
interrogé puisque je je je cite faisons
en sorte que chacun prenne ses
responsabilités avant d'imaginer la
création de machin qui aurait pour effet
de retarder un certain nombre d'actions
et de reporter de diluer les
responsabilités je pense que nous avons
aujourd'hui tout ce qui il faut pour que
le sursaut nécessaire puisse se produire
dans la vie fédérale le comité que vous
présidez est-il parvenu à la même
conclusion d'abord sur les comités
d'éthique nous propos nous réfléchissons
à proposer à les élargir à l'ensemble
des fédérations
agréées à faire en sorte comme je le
disais à l'instant que le Comité de
déontologie du
CNOSF puisse devenir un comité d'éthique
qui joue un rôle suprafédéral
c'est-à-dire qui puisse intervenir en
cas de
déficience du comité d'éthique de telle
ou telle fédération et qu'il puisse
aussi être source de moyens de
compétences pour seconder les comités
d'éthiqu nous pensons aussi qu'il faut
doter l'ensemble des comités d'éthique
d'un pouvoir
d'autosaisine que la saisie ne dépende
pas de la direction de la fédération et
de que tous les comités d'éthique
puissent
s'autosaisir et que tous leurs le leur
avis soit rendu transparent soit rendu
publ voilà donc si nous arrivons à
construire cette nouvelle
architecture nationale avec un rôle
nouveau pour le
CNOSF en soutien à des comités d'éthique
dont la composition la transparence la
sisine seront
modifié ça responsabilise bien le
mouvement sportif et ça lui donne des
outils pour mener ce combat éthique
alors on s'interroge et le débat est
toujours ouvert au sein du du Comité sur
faut-il notamment par rapport à ce qui
concerne les violences seis et
sexuell
faut-il se donner un outil extérieur au
mouvement sportif qu'on peut appeler
agence peut
appeler le mouvement sportif est assez
demandeur de cela parce que beaucoup des
personnes que nous avons auditionné
disent-nous sur ces questions on sait
pas faire
euh qu'est-ce que ça pose comme
interrogation c'est je sais pas s'il
faut l'appeler agence ENF appelonsla
agence pour simplifier c'est cet organe
extérieur il faudrait d'abord bien
délimiter son champ de
compétence est-ce qu'on est bien sur
violence sexuelle et sexiste
point ou est-ce qu'on élargit à d'autres
formes de violence et de discrimination
c'est-à-dire là on élargit très
largement à tout ce qui est
discrimination raciste homophobe c'est
bon
euh moi personnellement je serais pour
le cerner pour cerner son champ de
compétenence sur les violences ciste et
sexuel lui donnet-on un pouvoir de
sanction
je prends l'équivalence avec l'Agence
française de lutte contre le de page qui
a un pouvoir de contrôle mais qui a
aussi également un pouvoir de sanction
fait-on pareil si on avait un organisme
extérieur lui donn-on un pouvoir de
sanction direct
ou doit-il passer par le la nouvelle
architecture des comités d'éthique bon
voilà nous sommes encore en
débat je pense que nous allons trancher
dans les jours qui viennent mais nous
mais mais nous n'éclartons pas cette
piste c'est-à-dire nous voilà nous n
disons pas faut Pasut pas du tout
envisager cela nous travaillons
là-dessus
oui si je peux compléter dans notre
réflexion vis-à-vis des des fédérations
et sur la question des violences
sexuelles et sexistes notre souci par
rapport à une une autorité externe de de
de contrôle était de ne
pas contribuer au désengagement des
fédérations sur ces questionsl qui doit
qui doivent rester investis donc il y a
un équilibre à trouver il faut pas que
ce soit considéré comme une
sous-traitance d'un problème qui ne les
concerne pas ça pourrait être un message
qui pourrait être reçu de cette façon là
donc le le le la réflexion elle est dans
ce dans cette recherche d'équilibre à la
fois d'une efficacité qui est
indispensable sur ces sur ces questions
et et forcément on a réfléchi à
l'évolution de la lutte antidopage que
Madame buffet connaît très bien que j'ai
été membre de l'agence mondial
antidopage aussi quelques années donc
que je connais et et on sait ce que ce
qu'a apporté aujourd'hui l'indépendance
dans dans l'ensemble de la lutte
antidopage mondiale des agences avec le
pouvoir de contrôle et ce pouvoir de de
sanction pour autant voilà sur ce sur
ces sujets
là on souhaite que les fédérations
restent pleinement impliquées donc voilà
il y a un équilibre à trouver pour
l'instant on est toujours en réflexion
et on fera nos recommandation en prenant
en compte cette ces enjeux
d'équilibre
alors que pensez-vous du rôle que joue
le CNOSF
aujourd'hui puisque vous proposez de
changer ses missions en quelque sorte
et nous on les a entendu bien entendu
enfin on a reçu Monsieur massaglia on a
reçu Monsieur L'Appartien qui lui-même
d'ailleurs posait la question de
l'indépendance des comités d'éthiqu
puisque et là je le cite il disait les
liens avec l'exécutif n'en garantissent
pas l'impartialité et pourrait être
revisiter donc ça c'est les propos de
Monsieur L'Appartien on a eu l'occasion
d'entendre monsieur Masseglia qui quand
même était longtemps président du CNOSF
qui nous a indiquéit notamment sur le
volet VSS qu'il n'avait jamais été
informé de quoi que ce soit pendant
toute la durée de sa présidence donc
voilà nous on a eu beaucoup de
questionnements justement sur le rôle du
CNOSF en lien avec ces fédération quel
regard vous portez
dessus lors de nos
auditions nous avons posé cette question
à des dirigeants de club locaux à des
responsables de district à des
dirigeants
fédéraux qu'est-ce qu'ils attendaient du
son du CNOSF sur cette
question très souvent leur réponse était
rien je dis ça je dis pas ça en souriant
je je dis ça avec une certaine
gravité aujourd'hui le comité d'éthique
du CN SF existe de déontologie pardon du
CN SF existe une nouvelle présidente que
nous avons auditionné qui est très très
engagé pour ma part je pense que il est
de la responsabilité du
CNOSF d'être la tête de pont de ce
combat éthique il ne peut pas se
décharger sur les fédérations de cette
question c'est pourquoi personnellement
parmi
les débats que nous avons au comité je
soutiens l'idée je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure d'un comité d'éti suprafédéral
auocnosf en responsabilité donc du
combat éthique dans l'ensemble du
mouvement sportif français en lien avec
les comités éthique
existant en soutien des comités
d'éthique les plus faibles dans des
petites fédérations sans moyens et
cetera mais qui qui serait en
responsabilité par rapport à ce à ce
combat
j'ajoute que ce combat pour ma part ne
peut pas rester à l'intérieur de nos
frontières et que je pense que il serait
de l'intérêt du mouvement sportif et des
pratiquants et pratiquantes que la
France prenne
l'initiative de se tourner vers à
l'international pour essayer de
rassembler des états sur une exigence de
travailler à l'éthique au niveau du
mouvement sportif
international parce que je pense qu'on
peut bien sûr il faut s'occuper de ce
qui se passe dans notre pays mais il
faut aussi qu'on qu'on porte des
exigences par rapport euh au mouvement
sportifs international donc voilà oui il
faut responsabiliser je le dis
clairement pour ma part c'est ce que je
pense profondément il faut complètement
responsabiliser le CNOSF
euh dans ce combat pour l'éthique euh et
il faut qu'il en soit comptable par
rapport à la situation dans le mouvement
sportif français
oui si si l'on observe aussi ce qu' se
fait à l'étranger en la matière que ce
soit au niveau des des fédérations
internationales ou euh d'autres d'autres
États on a constaté aussi l'émergence
d'agences euh notamment aux États-Unis
pour ces questions-là avec euh c'est USS
sport je crois euh et euh certaines
agences qui ont euh un regard sur
l'intégrité beaucoup plus large et des
des prérogatives en matière de de
protection de l'intégrité tant de des
pratiquants des compétitions euh et des
institutions euh très très élargies donc
des compétences très élargies que ce
soit en Suisse ou dans d'autres pays
donc c'est aussi voilà des des modèles
qui que l'on a que l'on a regardé euh
pour autant c'est vrai qu'on pense que
le CNOSF doit avec bien sûr un comité
d'éthique qui garantisseent quoi qui qui
qui a une très forte indépendance à la
question de la nomination des membres de
ces comités d'éthiqu que ce soit aux
fédération ou euh dans dans une instance
comme on l'imagine au sein du CNOSF ne
peut fonctionner que si elle est
enrichie d'apport externe au sport et
qu'elle est
constitué d'apport de personne externe
extérieure au au mouvement sportif et si
elle est constituée bien sûr de manière
indépendante avec peut-être des enjeux
aussi de de mandat mandat politique de
voilà de déconnexion peut-être à
réfléchir entre les mandats politiques
et les mandats au sein de ces
instances j'ajouterais que il faut aussi
travailler sur les pouvoir des comités
d'éthique par exemple on est on s'est
beaucoup posé la question vous avez un
dirigeant
euh il y a une plainte de déposer
euh le procès est en cours
ou le procès eu lieu mais il y a un
appel est-ce que le comité d'éthique est
en capacité de décider de la mise en
retrait de la personne concernée c'est
une question
importante qu'il faut traiter qui pose
des tas de problèmes par rapport bien
sûr à la présomption d'innocence et tout
ça
mais je n'ai pas dit pouvoir de
démissionner quelqu'un j'ai dit pouvoir
de mise en retrait d'une personne par
rapport à
danger qu'il peut faire courir ou
voilà à sa fédération à des personnes
des choses comme ça donc il y a aussi à
définir quels sont quels sont les
pouvoirs exacts de ces comités
d'éthique les comités d'éthique ne sont
pas dotés de pouvoir disciplinaire ils
peuvent saisir l'organe disciplinaire
des faits dont ils ont eu connaissance
selon David L'Appartien il s'agit d'une
double procédure douloureuse et longue
ce qui le conduit à proposer de doter
les comités d'éthiqu de pouvoir
disciplinaires au moins sur des
questions de violence sexuelle que
pensez-vous de cette
proposition alors c'est un sujet que
l'on a abordé qui a fait débat au sein
au sein de la commission même entre
entre les responsables des comités
d'éthique de la de cette commission
celui de la Fédération Française de
Tennis Fran franc latin et de la
fédération de française de rugby Bernard
Fouchet
euh on est encore en en réflexion sur
ces questions-là
mais il est certain que ça le fait
d'avoir cette cette double cette double
cette étape préalable d'émission d'un
avis de saisine de la commission de
discipline et de décision de la
commission de discipline ça rallonge les
procédures ça c'est c'est évident et que
il serait bénéfique pour tout le monde
je pense de de pouvoir les les
raccourcir
euh si euh il y a la publication euh des
avis parce que c'est souvent aussi
l'opacité des décisions des commissés
des commissions des comités d'éthique
qui les fragilisent euh c'est euh ce qu'
appelle les Anglo-Saxons il a évoqué le
name and Shem c'est-à-dire voilà de
mettre sur la place public des décisions
et de renvoyer la responsabilité de la
décision à une commission de discipline
c'est quand même un un renforcement ce
serait quand même un renforcement du
pouvoir des comités d'éthique pour peser
sur la décision de la commission de
discipline euh mais voilà on est encore
en discussion et on prendra une décision
prochainement que pensez-vous de
l'ambition des contrats de délégation
signés en 2022 sur tous ces
enjeux l'idée était
bonne c'est-à-dire un engagement
réciproque
entre le mouvement sportif et l'État sur
toute une série de
d'objectifs encore faut-il ensuite que
l'État dispose des moyens de suivi de la
réalisation ou pas de ces contrats euh
de ces contrats
euh je rappelle quand même que le
ministère a perdu ses directions
départementales au niveau régional sa
représentation est dans les grandes
dragesses et je suis pas sûr que parfois
les représentants concernant des
dragesses concernant le sport ne sont
pas placés un peu en bout de
table donc voilà s'il y a pas ce ces
moyens de contrôle je dirais de contrôle
et d'accompagnement pour des fédés qui
sont plus plus plus en difficulté et
cetera euh
on peut signer ces contrats mais leur
effectivité est sujette à caution quand
même voilà
c'est j'entends sur le volet contrôle
c'est effectivement une des difficultés
qu'on a pu ressentir dans le cadre des
auditions aussi mais concernant le
peut-être le contenu l'ambition qui est
affichée dans ces contrats de
délégation notamment sur le volet
éthique sur les VSS voilà est-ce que
voilà qu'est-ce que vous en pensez sur
justement sur en terme d'ambition
oui c'est c'est un élément que l'on a
que l'on a abordé au sein de au sein de
la commission qui pour nous de manière
assez unanime fait clairement défaut la
le pilotage historique de la relation du
ministère avec les fédérations de la ns
maintenant avec les fédérations c'est
beaucoup basé sur le développement de la
pratique et c'est très bien c'est un
enjeu un enjeu important les résultats
sportifs on sait aussi les enjeux que ça
peut représenter mais mais c'est vrai
que il y a un manque sans doute euh dans
le pilotage je dirais de la relation euh
avec les fédérations sur ces
questions-là euh sans doute parce que
elles étaient sont moins présentes
historiquement dans la société au-delà
du au-delà des enjeux liés au mouvement
sportif elles le sont aujourd'hui et
forcément ça va être pour moi et je
pense pour l'ensemble
euh des des des acteurs de de de cette
des membres de cette commission pardon
euh ça doit être aujourd'hui intégré on
a évoqué bien sûr les violences sexistes
et sexuelles mais
euh pour connaître un peu le le le la
question du sport de haut niveau euh la
pression de la performance on sait très
bien on a parlé du dopage mais on sait
très bien le le type tout tout système
de performance peut produire des effets
pervers en matière euh de respect de
l'intégrité de la personne de
développement de la la personne et donc
bien sûr qu'il y a des des choses à
mettre en place qui vont au-delà de la
lutte antidopage qui vont sur les
violences sexistes et sexuelles mais qui
aussi concernent je dirais la la
performance sociale du haut niveau
comment on produit de la performance de
haut niveau à quel coût avec quel risque
et donc les identifier les sécuriser on
est dans des aujourd'hui dans des
dispositifs euh qui sont plus de l'ordre
du je dirais de l'obligation de moyens
en matière de suivi professionnel
socioprofessionnel ça a été renforcé
dans les fédérations avec des
obligations de formation avec un euh une
qualification à avoir pour occuper ses
fonctions au sein des fédérations mais
il y a encore un travail à faire pour
suivre l'itinéraire
postcrière sociale des sportifs qui ont
été sur les listes ministérielles
peut-être de rallonger la période de
suivi euh de renforcer les dispositifs
d'accompagnement et sans doute sortir de
l'obligation de moyens pour aller vers
euh des choses qui relèvent plus de
l'objectif accompagn il s'agit pas de
sanctionner il faut accompagner faire
évoluer euh les pratiques euh en la
matière il s'agit aussi là de protection
des pratiquants et des pratiquantes si
euh le fait de servir les couleurs
nationales conduit à une grande
fragilité sociale par la
suite alors juste j'entends tout à fait
hein mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
qu'une question administrative là les
contrats de délégation c'est comme des
orientations politiques c'est validé à
l'échelle aussi politique en terme
d'ambition sur ces contrats de
délégation donc c'est là en fait nous on
s'est beaucoup questionné sur bah tous
ces aspects là c'està dire l'éthique la
probité les violences sexuelles et
sexistes le racisme on a le sentiment
d'ailleurs qui nous a été confirmé en
quelque sorte par la Direction des
Sports qui nous a dit que finalement ces
contrats de délégation étaient un
premier g écrit très rapidement pour
être signé
rapidement alors oui oui mais ça va dans
ça va dans ce sens il manque des
objectifs clairs et précis avec des
indicateurs de mesures sans doute
euh peut-être de d'évaluation externes
aussi des fédérations sur ces
questions-là il y a sans doute des des
fédérations qui sont plus performant sur
certains critères euh sociétaux que
d'autres on le sait pas bien aujourd'hui
on ne sait pas trop on sait pas le
mesurer et sans doute que des outils de
mesure qui permettent aussi aux
fédérations de s'évaluer sur différents
critères pourrai leur permettre
d'avancer sur ces sur ces choses là mais
ce qui ne se se mesure pas est difficile
à piloter donc je pense qu'il faut
donner des
indications et des orientations qui
doivent être dans le dans le contrat de
délégation une question de notre
collègue Stéphane
bûchou merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre monsieur
Diagana
juste revenir sur sur un certain nombre
de choses
que que que vous avez dit d'abord saluer
le travail que vous que vous faites sur
sur le sujet qui nous qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui et qui nous qui nous occupe
et qui nous préoccupe ça a été dit très
fortement
euh
simplement vous disiez tout à l'heure
madame la
ministre pour reprendre les termes pour
reprendre vos termes il faut
responsabiliser
euh contte tenu des des des auditions
que nous avons que nous nous avons mené
plus de 90 ça a été rappelé tout à
l'heure parfois de l'intensité et de la
gravité des faits qui nous ont qui nous
ont été
révélé moi je je me pose la question et
et donc du coup je vous la pose sur
l'aspect de la responsabilisation est-ce
qu'on en est encore à
responsabiliser enfin je je veux dire
par là est-ce qu'il faut pas aller plus
loin que la que la responsabilisation
aujourd'hui on est
et on le voyait tout à l'heure lors de
l'audition du du garde des
sauts parfois dans des des des zones
d'ombre
dans pour lesquels on n pas de réponse
on n pas de réponse et en fait la
question enfin ou les questions en
l'occurrence sur ces comités d'éthique
est-ce quand vous vous posez la question
de savoir s'il doit y avoir une autorité
indépendante ou est-ce qu'il faut vous
disiez monsieur Diagana peut-être un
appliquer celles et ceux qui sont déjà
au
responsabilités à ce stade il y a pas de
jugement dans ma bouche vous n'avez pas
encore complètement
tranché une des questions c'est on l'a
vu au travers des auditions que nous
avons mené on a on est dans un petit
monde au final où tout le monde se
connaît une forme d'entre soi ça a été
dit très régulièrement est-ce que par
exemple si dans la volonté qui peut être
la vôtre de dire bah on va pas être sur
une sur une sur une entité indépendante
mais on va réimpliquer celles et ceux
qui sont déjà au responsabilité est-ce
qu'on est-ce qu'on va être vraiment dans
l'efficacité effectivement la question
la la question se pose en tous les cas
pour
résumer au sortir de toutes ces
auditions il y a une volonté très
marquée d'un certain nombre d'acteurs
président de fédération par exemple qui
souhaite beaucoup de fermeté aller très
loin on
a un certain nombre de
blocages et donc est-ce que tout ça vous
l'avez vous l'avez pris en compte et
encore une fois et même si la question
est particulièrement
complexe comment on fait comment fait-on
collectivement pour que bah tous ces
sujets qui font l'objet des travaux de
cette commission l'identification je
pense qu'elle est faite et elle va
continuer à être faite parce qu'on a et
on a on a très modestement fait œuvre
utile parce que on a
enfin je pense permis à à de nombreuses
personnes de libérer leurs paroles mais
une fois qu'on a franchi
cap comment on fait pour que celles et
ceux qui n'ont pas agi au moment ils
auraient où ils auraient dû agir ne
puisse plus le faire et qu'on parte
pardon de le dire de cette manière un
peu triviale mais du bon
pied pardon oui sur la question sur la
question des des comités des comité
d'éthique il est sûr qu'en l'état par
rapport au constat qu'on a pu faire de
des procédures de nomination des
procédures d'appel à candidature des
profils de de cette effectivement entre
soi qui conduit à une composition très
homogène des des profils ça ne pourra
pas fonctionner en revanche
si l'indépendance de nomination est
garantie si on va chercher à mettre un
peu d'oxygène et euh aller chercher des
ressources à l'extérieur de de personnes
compétentes pour venir travailler
prendre les décisions y
réfléchir on se donnera plus de chance
est-ce que ce sera efficace est-ce que
il faut absolument et tout de suite
aller vers une autorité indépendante sur
cette question là comme comme pour la
lutte contre le dopage on est encore
voilà on est encore en réflexion on
espère que que cela puisse fonctionner
en mais avec une refonte complète de la
façon dont ces comités d'éthique sont
sont structurés sont sont sont tout
simplement
voilà bâti dès le départ il y a un
problème de dépendance on l'a vu je sais
pas si j'imagine que dans vos auditions
aussi de voilà c'est un ancien président
de Lig qui connaî donc ça comme ça non
on est convaincu que ça ne sera pas la
hauteur de de l'enjeu et de la
tâche pour aller dans dans le sens de ce
que vient de dire monsieur Stéphane
diagan il faut que
la composition des comités
d'éthique sort ces comités d'éthique de
l'entre soi donc je pense par exemple
pour comité d'
suprafédéral je souhaiterais il faut
qu'on ait des nomination qui viennent de
grandes institution
républicaines peut-être une
représentation
parlementaire voilà il faut qu'on a
vraiment une
participation de personnes qui par le
respons ité au sein de notre pays au
sein de notre République sont en
capacité de faire preuve de compétence
d'autorité et surtout de ne pas être
excusez-moi l'expression dans la famille
voilà donc ça c'est c'est tout ce qui
tourne autour de la composition des
comités d'éthique il faut pas que
l'élection la nomination des comités
d'éthique se fasse juste dans la foulée
de l'élection de la direction fédérale
et que parfois on mette à la présidence
du comité d'éthique l'ancien dirigeant
qui est plus dirigeant parce qu'il y a
un nouveau dirigeant bon voilà c'est ça
paraît ça paraît le B àas mais c'est
c'est c'est nécessaire de de leur dire
ensuite je pense qu'il y a d'autres
facteurs qu'il faut sur lequel il faut
qu'on
agisse moi je pense profondément qu'on a
un problème de
formation je pense qu'il faut une
réforme vraiment systémique de la
formation initiale continue de nos
éducateurs et de nos entraîneurs il faut
des modules de formation oblig
concernant notamment tout ce qui
concerne les dossiers éthiques les
dossiers et cetera il faut que voilà il
y a eu un moment il existait un institut
de formation au sein du CNOSF en 2016 je
croisou il a disparu moi je pense qu'il
faut recréer un institut de formation
contrôler et qui justement soit en
capacité de dispenser ces modules
nécessaire ça c'est la deuxème chose la
troème chose c'est les moyens de
contrôle de l'État je je le redis encore
une fois il faut que ce ministère
regagne en capacité humaine en capacité
financière pour exercer ce contrôle et
puis peut-être que je vais chauter en
disant ça
fondamentalement je pense que ce combat
nous arriverons vraiment à aller au bout
ce combat pour l'éthique si un
renouvellement dans les postes de
responsabilité du mouvement sportif et
en disant cela je
ne je ne fais pas un jure à ceux et
celles qui dirigent aujourd'hui le
mouvement sportif ils ont consacré une
partie de leur vie au développement du
sport et tout mais le constat est là
qu'ils sont souvent en décalage avec les
exigences sociétal social et cetera
éthique de notre société il faut qu'il y
ait un
renouvellement et ce renouvellement je
l'ai dit au début il passera par une une
vie démocratique renouvelée et puis il
faut donner envie à l'engagement
bénévole
alors je vais pas revenir sur le statut
du bénévole ça fait 50 ans que tout le
monde en parle et que il se passe pas
grand-chose ne prononçons plus cette
formule essayons de voir quelle mesure
pourrait donner envie à de nouvelles
générations de ne pas rester une
responsabilité au niveau de leur viille
mais d'aller voilà de mener le débat à
l'intérieur de la fédération de de se
présenter dans au moment électoral et
cetera moi je pense hein qu'il faut une
grille
d'indemnisation des futurs dirigeants et
dirigeantes du mouvement sportif avec
contrepartie
indemnisation transparence parce qu'on
sait qu'il y a des fédés qui sont
capables de rénumérer puis il y a des
fédés qui peuvent pas il y a des fédé
qui ont beaucoup de salariés et des
fédés qu'en ont pas bon donc il faut une
grille transparente d'indemnisation j'ai
pas parlé de rénumération mais avec
contreparti par exemple au niveau de la
formation voilà si on si on donne pas il
faut certainement qu'on revienne sur les
les trimestres de retraite sur les
décharges horaires sur tout ça il faut
qu'on qu'on donne envie à de jeunes
dirigeantes à de jeunes dirigeants
d'aller chercher des responsabilités
dans les fédérations si on si on s'il y
a pas ce bouger ça sera beaucoup plus
long de mener le de mener le le combat
éti je le je le pense profondément suite
à toutes les auditions qu'on a fait et
je dis bien dans en respectant tout à
fait ces hommes et ces femmes qui se
sont investis sur sur cette question oui
il faut qu'on nouvelle mais c'est vrai
dans le mouvement sportif c'est parfois
vrai en politique ou dans d'autres
secteurs de la société j'ai pas de leçon
à donner au mouvement sportif on
pourrait aussi se regarder nous-mêm dans
la vie
politique une question de Pascal
Martin bonjour monsieur Diagana et
bonjour madame la ministre euh moi j'ai
j'ai noté la phrase que vous avez
prononcé tout à l'heure madame la
ministre en en disant que c'était un
athlète de l'INSEP qui qui vous avait
dit cela j'aime it de temps en temps ne
plus être considéré comme un sportif
mais comme un individu comme un être
humain en quelque sorte et euh bon le
monde sportif je le connais plus ou
moins on va dire et je je je m'intéresse
du coup beaucoup là cette commission
d'enquête parce que en fait le monde
sportif c'est aussi le reflet de la
société vous venez d'en parler
et il y a plusieurs personnes qui nous
ont témoigné du fait que dans d'autres
pays il y a un accompagnement parce que
cette phrase m'a fait penser à cela en
fait je je je ressens que dans ce monde
sportif et en d'autant plus au sport de
haut niveau on fait des êtres humains
des des espèces de machines à gagner et
on laisse un peu de côté l'humanité de
de ces personnes et euh donc dans
certains pays il y a euh des des
psychologues qui accompagnent les
sportifs et d'après ce que j'ai entendu
j'espère ne pas me trop Tromp il
semblerait qu'en France on soit en gros
déficit de de d'accompagnement et qu'en
fait ça dépend aussi des moyens qu'on
les fédérations puisque dans certaines
fédérations j'imagine que cet
accompagnement psychologique est mis en
place et dans
d'autres sans doute très peu voire pas
du tout donc je voulais savoir ce que
vous pensiez de de cette question de
l'accompagnement des sportif euh parce
qu'il me paraît indispensable enfin on
peut pas il y a aussi de athlètes au
tout début de la commission d'enquête
qui nous disait que parce que les Joos
arrivaient en fait voilà on en faisait
comme je viens de le dire excusez-moi
l'expression je m'en excuse auprès d'eux
et elle des machines à gagner je trouve
cela très regrettable donc que
pensez-vous est-ce que vous avez pu vous
au travers de votre expérience et de
votre
expertise faire ce constat aussi est-ce
que vous avez des préconisations
juste peut-être avant que vous répondiez
il me semble mais je voudrais pas dire
de bêtises que au moment des auditions
on a aussi eu une personne qui nous a
dit que par exemple pour la délégation
française au jop de 2024 il n'y aurait
qu'un psychologue pour toute la
délégation française donc voilà c'est un
sujet qui nous a beaucoup aussi
questionné sur l'accompagnement de ces
sportifs y compris d'ailleurs quand on
parle de bien-être et d'accompagnement
de nos athlètes et bien la question du
suivi psychologique est un est un est un
vrai sujet
oui donc plus plus plus globalement et
c'est vrai que il y a un vrai sujet sur
la santé les athlètes mais quand je
parle de santé je la pense bien dans ces
trois dimensions he celle de la
définition de l'OMS qui date de 1946 la
santé psychique physique et social et et
et donc je pense qu'il y a il y a un
déficit de de de prévention
d'accompagnement en particulier je l'
évoqué sur la santé sociale c'est-à-dire
que quand on sort des listes d'athlètes
qui ont couru sous les
couleurs du maillot
national on sait pas trop l'itinéraire
on voit qu'il y a quand même beaucoup de
difficultés donc ça interroge le système
et on voit bien ces témoignages qui
disent B on sent la pression des Jeux
Olympiques l'obtention des médailles
tous les systèmes de performance que ce
soit en entreprise ou dans le sport sont
soumis au même questionnement comment on
veut produire de la performance à quel
coût quels sont les risques les
identifier les prévenir qu'est-ce que
l'on accepte qu'est-ce que l'onaccepte
pas donc je crois que c'est vraiment une
question de responsabilité du mouvement
sportif sur ces questions-là les sujets
de la le sujet de la santé mentale
arrive maintenant sur la place publique
avec il vient pas de France en premier
c'est plutôt ce sont plutôt des des des
sportifs étrangers qui l'ont qui l'ont
évoqué et c'est très bien parce que ça
permet aux sportifs de et aux sportifs
de pouvoir euh aborder ces sujetslà plus
sereinement pour qu'on y apporte des
réponses donc il y a un retard euh il y
a un retard en France je connais
effectivement des systèmes où euh les
athlètes sont accompagnés euh au
Pays-Bas en athlétisme par des coachs de
vie voilà qui vont les accompagner aussi
euh on a du il y a du travail dans ce
domaine-là et on est plutôt plutôt en
retard en effet
euh après sur le sur la question de la
santé physique c'est peut-être là où euh
il y a un petit peu plus de suivi mais
euh mais une fois de plus voilà on est
dans un on n'est pas dans une dirais il
faut pas regarder non plus le sport
comme quelque chose qui forcément
conduit à à la dégradation de la santé
dans la plupart des cas c'est un facteur
de santé formidable dans tous les clubs
sur le plan social et c'est vrai que là
on a une focalisation sur les problèmes
les dysfonctionnements mais la plus pour
la plupart des des personnes qui vivent
le sport au quotidien dans un club il
faut rappeler que c'est un facteur de
santé physique mentale et sociale et
qu'aujourd'hui
cette c'est c'est bénéfices pour la
société c'est le mouvement sportif en
grande partie qui le qui les rend
possible et donc il s'agit pas de de
construire pour pour traiter les
dysfonctionnements de de de construire
contre le mouvement sportif mais avec le
mouvement sportif une fois de plus le le
le le le bénévolat est quand même en
difficulté hein la vcation de bénévole
c'est aujourd'hui pour pour beaucoup de
raisons qui seraiit long d'expliquer
mais c'est une difficulté donc il faut
avoir aussi
dans la prise en charge de ces tous les
problèmes qu'on a évoqué aujourd'hui
cette
cette situation bien en tête pour ne pas
non plus faire fuir les voocations qu'on
a déjà du mal à avoir sous le poids des
responsabilités sous le doigt accusateur
qui pourrait se dire bah voilà si je
veux être tranquille maintenant moi je
je prends plus de responsabilité et je
rends les clés de mon club je je je fais
un raccourci mais voilà il faut avoir
ceci à l'esprit à mon avis c'est
important que ça se fasse dans une
logique d'accompagnement de
coconstruction avec le mouvement sportif
et c'est pour ça que je partage tout à
fait ce qui a été dit en introduction
par Madame buffet à savoir que il faudra
qu'il y ait une consultation pour que
pour pour travailler avec le mouvement
sportif qui est un état des lieux clair
qui est une prise de
conscience des enjeux et des attentes et
construire avec le mouvement sportif les
solutions les plus adaptées pour qu'elle
soit mise en œuvre partagé et qu' a une
vraie adhésion sur sur la feuille de
route juste par rapport à votre question
madame la rapporte
nous allons certainement proposer de
modifier l'article
231-5 du code du sport pour justement
élargir le rôle et lesémission des
fédérations dans le domaine de la
protection des sportifs en citant de
façon claire les la question de la
psychologie donc de faire rentrer dans
cet article pas simplement les questions
physiques mais aussi les
questions psychiques donc pour que les
fédération soit en responsabilité par
rapport à ça ça c'est une proposition
très concrète que nous faisons alors
après le sport est aussi le reflet de la
société les dérives l'a dit tout à
l'heure les drives qui traversent le
sport sont celles qui traversent la
société mais je dirais le sport aussi
dans sa
pratique obéit à certains codes dans la
société quand quand le débat sur le
sport se réduit au résultat sportif ou
au spectacle
sportif euh bien évidemment euh la
question de la performance du résultat
devient un peu le le le le voilà le le
le guide de de d'un certain nombre
d'agissement d'un certain nombre de de
pratiqu dans le mouvement sportif dans
une audition on nous expliquait par
exemple que des parents ne voient pas la
nécessité que des jeunes qui sont en
centre de formation euh rentre le
weekend et que parfois en lien avec des
entraîneurs il disent non faut mieux
qu'il reste dans le centre de formation
ça lui permet de s'entraîner et cetera
euh donc on voit bien comment la
pression peut s'exercer euh y compris de
la part parfois des plus proches des
athlètes avec l'idée du
résultat donc c'est comment on dessert
cette conception du sport basée que sur
la performance et le résultat c'est ce
que disait
Stéphane une question de Monsieur
François peekmal
oui bonjour madame buffet et Monsieur
Diagana désolé pour mon retard euh
j'aurais une question pour vous Madame
buffet vous plaidez actuellement pour
que soit consacré 1 % du budget de
l'État dans le ministère du sport en
tout cas le sport contre 0,3 %
actuellement et moi j'aimerais mais ça
peut s'adresser à vous aussi monsieur
Diagana savoir est-ce que cette position
a été entendue par l'actuel ministre ou
par le gouvernement et deuxième chose
quel serait selon vous les dépenses
prioritaires qu'il faudrait faire dans
ce budget et notamment sur le thème qui
nous concerne c'est-à-dire la lutte
contre les discriminations les VSS mais
aussi le bien-être des sportifs et des
structures sportives je vous
remercie on n'arrête
pas de parler de l'héritage des jop moi
jeurépute un peu cette formule
l'héritage chez toi oui il y a le basin
olympique moi je passe devant à chaque
fois je par chez moi bon il y a la
nouvelle piscine à Marville il y a bon
oui dans Sony des bâtiments là qui qui
qui ont été construits pour les
goop bon mais rappelons-nous les Jeux de
Londres progression des licenciés sur 2
ans puis rechute des
licenciés donc moi j'ai plutôt envie de
me de me dire est-ce qu'on se saisit de
l'opportunité magnifique d'avoir voir
les jop en
2024 pour développer un grand débat et
développer une grande ambition sur le
développement de la pratique sportive en
France c'est pour ça que j'ai lancé
l'idée faisons lançons le défi que dans
la prochaine olympiade 2024
2028 le budget des sports passe de 0,03
à 1 %. c'est un beau souvenir que ce
beau combat des hommes et des femmes de
culture pour le 1 % pour la culture je
pense que le sport par rapport au rôle
qui joue dans le développement des êtres
humains et dans les liens sociaux vaut
vaut ce 1 % voilà donc je pense que faut
saisir l'opportunité là pourquoi faire
mais peut-être en lien avec tout ce
qu'on vient de de
débattre nous avons besoin de
compétences nouvelles dans le
développement du sport parce que le
sport est confronté à des enjeux la
marchandisation je sais pas si vous avez
vu vu les je vais pas faire la pub pour
un journal mais enfin bon les le
quotidien sportif titre sur le monoague
Monopoly League avec le contrat de la de
la LFP l LFP LFP oui LFP pardon
euh donc a ces enjeux de marchandisation
euh ces enjeux
d'instrumentalisation au niveau
géopolitique on voit bien aujourd'hui
comment des États plus ou moins
démocratiques
utilise le sport pour assoir un
rayonnement international bon donc face
à tout cela quel peut être l'utilisation
de l'argent moi je crois qu'il faut
pouvoir fournir au mouvement sportifs
dirigés par des bénévoles fournir des
les moyens d'avoir de la compétence
c'est-à-dire il faut développer l'emploi
salarié dans le mouvement sportif avec
des hommes et des femmes formés pour
répondre aux enjeux de notre époque je
pense que là déjà ça serait un bel
investissement deuxème
investissement tout ce qui
concerne l'équipement
sportif encore
aujourd'hui l'absence de certains
équipements freine le développement de
la pratique je vais prendre l'exemple de
la natation on sait le coût d'une
piscine le coût de fonctionnement pour
une une ville d'une piscine seulement il
y a des départements où un enfant sur
deux rentre au collège il sait pas nager
donc l'aide à l'équipement auprès des
collectivités territoriales me paraît le
deuxème le deuxème investissement à
prendre et je pense ensuite
l'indemnisation des bénévoles me paraît
aussi une piste de dépenses
utile alors Monsieur Ludovic Roy a jugé
au cours de son audition qu'il serait
intéressant de décorréler le temps
politique du temps technique et que donc
les DTN voi leur mission d'agentch teque
totalement synchronisé avec le mandat
politique d'un président d'une
association que pensez-vous de cette
proposition tout à l'heure vous avez
évoqué la question des comités d'éthique
le fait qu'on décorrèle l'élection d'un
nouveau bureau fédéral avec l'élection
du comité d'éthique est-ce que vous ne
pensez pas qu'on peut faire la même
chose avec les DTN qui souvent en fait
sont nommés de manière concomitante avec
le président de la
Fédération alors c'est vrai que c'est la
la la la pratique est celle-ci le DTN
est est chargé normalement de de mettre
en œuvre une politique fédérale et cette
politique fédérale elle est décidée par
le président élu donc ça me paraît
j'avais pas réfléchi à cette question
mais ça me paraît logique d'avoir un DTN
qui qui soit choisi aussi en fonction
peut-être de sa sensibilité bon la la
coopération avec entre le président et
le DTN est importante aussi soit des
personnes qui qui est une bonne relation
ça peut être un facteur quand même de
succès
et puis surtout qui qui un DTN qui se
sent à même de mettre en place une
politique donnée avec des orientation
qui peut être différent d'un président à
l'autre je je sais pas j'aurais aimé
poser la question de savoir quels
étaient les enjeux derrière euh par
rapport à à cette question là euh parce
que si elle est posée c'est que sans
doute il y a une réflexion que je n'ai
peut-être pas sur le
sujet si vous permettez madame la
rapporteur
nous avons constaté pendant les
auditions que certains destn pouvaient
occuper en même temps la responsabilité
de directeur général de la
Fédération là ça nous semble un conflit
d'intérêt important parce que le DTN a
ses missions auprès de la fédération
mais c'est un agent de
l'État et donc je pense que nous
retiendrons dans No nos propositions le
fait d'interdire le cumul entre des
postes de responsabilité dans les
fédérations et l'émission des
DTN parce que ça nous semble
incompatible pardon merci oui notamment
si on on se projette dans des voilà des
des faits graves sur une fédération un
DTN qui est un agent de l'État et qui
est en même temps à la tête d'une
fédération se trouverait je dirais
contrôlé par le le ministère ou entendu
par le ministère alors qu'il est agent
donc il y a des des voilà il y a des il
y a un sujet de ce côté-là qui nous a
paru quo qui nous a conduit à avoir
cette cette
réflexion alors on s'est posé la même
question il nous avait semblé que
c'était assez clair que c'était interdit
mais que dans les fait ça se pratiquait
avec l'autorisation du ministère des
Sports donc oui on partage voilà DTN et
DG c'est un
problème
merci à vous nous clôturons avec vous
les auditions de cette commission
d'enquête merci à vous merci Madame
Présidente je souhaite que les
conclusions de ces
deux de votre commission d'enquête et de
notre comité permettent voilà que des
choses bougent et et que les bénévoles
du mouvement sportif soi
accompagné dans le travail remarquable
que beaucoup d'entre eux font parce
qu'il faut toujours avoir ça en tête
merci